G of X is a transformation of f of X the
graph here shows this is y is equal to f
of X two solid blue line this is y is
equal to G of X as a dashed red line and
they ask us what is G of X in terms of f
of X and like always pause the video and
see if you can give a go at it and then
we're going to do it together
alright so when you immediately look
like it looks like G of X is kind of a
thinned up version of f of X it seems
like if you were to compress it to
towards the center that's what G of X
looks like but let's put a little bit
more meat on that bone and see if we can
identify corresponding points so for
example if we were to look at f of
negative 6 that's so f of negative 6
that seems like it corresponds or gives
us the same value as f of negative 6 and
we want to find the corresponding point
so we've hit this minimum point we're
coming back up
hit the minimum point we're coming back
up it seems like the corresponding point
right over there is G of negative 3 so
let's write that down let's see it looks
like F of negative 6 and it is equal to
G of negative 3 these are corresponding
points if you apply the transportation
at the point f equals at the point
negative 6 comma F of negative 6 you get
to the point negative 3 G of negative 3
right over there let's do a couple of
more if you look at F is so f of 2 looks
like it corresponds to G of 1 F of 2
corresponds to G of 1 so let's write
that down
f of 2 looks like it corresponds to G of
1 and once again I'm looking at the
where the functions hit the same value
and also optically I'm just looking at
what it looks like it's the same part of
the function if we assume G of X is a
squeezed version of f of X and so in
general it looks like it looks like for
given X so we could say f of X is going
to be equal to G of well whatever you
have in here it seems like we have half
the value over here so G of x over 2 or
if you wanted to think of it the other
way if you wanted to think of the other
way if you want to say G of X is going
to be f of well whatever we have here
it's f
twice that so F of 2x and we see that
that is one of the choices that G of X
is equal to F of 2x whatever the X that
you input into G of X you get that same
value out of the function when you input
two times that into f of X and these
these seem to validate that it looks
optically like that that we shrunk it
down one way to think about it when you
take when you multiply the the input
into a function by a number larger than
then one it's going to compress it's
going to make things happen faster the
input to the function is going to
increase or become negative faster so
it's true it thins it up and if that
doesn't make intuitive sense you can
also just try to try some of these
values and I encourage you to try more
find the corresponding points where the
F's and the G's seem to match up and
you'll see you over and over again that
to get the same value you have to put
two times as much into F as you have to
put into G hopefully that helps